we're heading to the cup Kapalua coastal
trail
[Music]
you
these views are so pretty I passed this
rock it's back to be
[Music]
breathe on a mission she is a whole
schedule plan she's got an itinerary
printed out and ready to go and we are
thirty minutes behind schedule
somebody's got a twitch back and
rain rain rain my first time in Maui
years and years ago one of the coolest
things that I thought was chickens that
were strolling around
I thought these were all rocks but they
are actually Turtles
[Music]
they'll you different ways to be all the
more reasons it'll be sad when hard
words turn the good into the bed
shameiess is so good I just got through
here and was a whoopie float
you just started filming just as I did I
give up Pacolet wall Brianne went to the
Christmas store again though she is she
see us
brie the scene of the crime is our last
day here actually we're leaving now - ok
we're packing up now to head to the
airport but if I'd get blown the last
time lapse the moon looks so pretty
[Music]
thanks for the sandwich gentle are you
writing a nice note brief yeah bye-bye
sweet house we had such a lovely time
here in Hawaii and this house is
beautiful I'm so sad to see you go I
also have many memories of tragedy did
you just drop your camera in there you
have to go get them Mahalo Aloha not
looking forward to getting on a plane
that's for sure
where's dropping mom great is it time
for spooks yet you're annoying but it's
time for spot time for spooks rub her
out our flights not for three hours we
try to check our bag and there's no one
there I just got a pineapple night
pillow
pineapple pinch do we get Starbucks or
what okay I don't know you look silly
Justin yeah did you ever lose wine after
another across trembler made it
[Music]
I've been sung so many times by
centipedes I think that I might be
turning into one boom zap it by the
light over here serious Oh God
Oh Sammy they're gone we're back in Los
Angeles and now we have to say goodbye
to BRE
bye Bri dude Korean has the worst flight
ever she has two more plates she won't
get home until tomorrow and then she's a
bigger car and then drive it when you go
to work Oh God but you know what let me
tell you about this disgusting person
that was in the aisle next to me whoa
they had a pineapple on their head
in a place for us I will show you where
to go I won't try to change your mind
cuz I'm always on your side
time moves fast
so when you're by my side
it's so
to get by I'm leavin all my troubles
behind I will give it to you cuz you
make it easy
you make it also
now
[Music]
I will show you
won't try
let's change your
Oh
[Music]
well everyone we made it back home safe
and sound
picked up Matty he had such a lovely
time at camp he's exhausted
are you sleepy hum do you want to show
everyone your new haircut so Maddie has
really thin hair in the last time that I
took him to the groomers I didn't get
his haircut which was a huge mistake
he got his hair so matted from having
the time of his little life and not
getting his hair cut at the last time
when to the groomers so he had to pretty
much shave his little bod hey let's show
you in your body he looks like the
freaking blanket ready let's get up come
on yeah show them show them oh honey you
look so silly
I'm so sorry my little doggy oh honey
I'm so I'm not I'm laughing with you I'm
laughing with you my babe my sweet babe
it'll grow back his hair grows so quick
that we have to take him to the groomer
like every week it's insane we'll help
you guys enjoyed all the Hawaii videos
and all the drone shots I had so much
fun flying my drone they love being able
to fly it over water because I don't
have to worry about anything other than
losing the drone in the water but it's
sort of like this freedom of I can fly
it and if it happens to just fall out of
the air I'm not gonna hurt anybody I'm
not gonna hurt myself I just lose a
drone but that's that's the price you
pay for I guess
being reckless and we all know that the
price of being reckless
has cost me a camera but yeah
how's everything sound and how's
everything looking how's everything
sound and how's everything looking